going to take a turn now to a pride
month event we're having coming up right
here a celebration of leaders in the
lgbtq community part of our series
changing the game and what we do with
that is we highlight extraordinary women
who are making a difference now and for
future Generations Emma McElroy is
founder and CEO of wildfang it is a
gender fluid clothing company and
McElroy launched it way back in 2013
after she noticed that certain
Silhouettes like Blazers and tailored
pants were not available to women in the
same quality and fit as for men the
clothes are available online or in one
of the brands to retail stores in
Portland and Los Angeles and celebrities
like Janelle Monae have stepped out in
wildfang Ware and the company has raised
more than a million dollars for charity
so we're very glad to welcome Emma
McElroy to the show Emma thank you for
being here yes of course uh so you have
there's a quote here and I don't know if
it's the right one here so I'm to start
with it you got to explain clothes or
just clothes are they
look there's been a lot of things that
have been passed on from generation to
Generation
Um around gender Norms right how we get
to show up in the world how we get to
talk what jobs we get to do Emma you
remember the phrase closed make the man
yeah exactly yeah it's a man right and
so
um
clothes are a really important part of
how we express ourselves Tony right so
it's how we show up in the world how we
want others to see ourselves and at
wildfine we just like to play with that
right we want to take those norms and we
want to sort of throw them out the
window and just have a little bit more
fun so you're saying kind of both things
like clothes are really important they
are how you express they are a
representation of identity but at the
same time don't overthink it and don't
go with what was you can go in any
direction you want correct however you
want to show up in the world we get you
so you started this company 10 years ago
and you started why were you out
shopping around and saying I need X Y
and Z and it's not here what happened
exactly so I walked into a department
store with my best friend and we both
walk through the women's Department I
was looking for a great graphic tee she
was looking for a great Blazer and all
the Blazers in the women's section had
like those weird fake Pockets yes where
you can only get your fingernails yes
and the fake Pockets right and so we
wandered through and we end up in the
men's department and then lo and behold
that is where all the great Blazers were
hanging out right and the great graphic
T's that were bold and provocative and
strong and so we were like well wit why
can't a woman have a great Blazer feel
right so we decided that was where it
came from you know I love that you see
this crossover quite a bit you see women
that might want to bag your fit and like
oh I have to go to the men's section to
find this or a guy he may see a beanie
or some accessories my wife might be
wearing something I'm like you know what
after she's done I'm taking that to my
side of the deposit and I'm aware of
that beanie because I like the colorway
um so you creating this brand it's
absolutely genius and necessary so well
done it's been profitable profitable
quickly growing
what do you think is the reason for this
success so soon
I think we put our customer at the heart
and soul of every decision I think
everything for US starts and ends with
the person that walks through our doors
you know what do they want what makes
them feel great and that guides every
decision and I think I think our brand
has a heartbeat and I think our customer
feels that well you say we're here to
rewrite the future of gender what what
does that mean exactly to you Emma so
like I said there's all these rules that
have been passed on right like jobs that
at one point you and I weren't able to
do right or ways that you weren't able
to show up ways that we weren't able to
talk and
um all those Norms all those rules
connected to uh your gender we we just
want to throw them out the window and we
want to allow you to be exactly who you
want to be and show up exactly how you
want to show up and challenging these
Norms as a queer founder did you have
different challenges when you first
started out the business yeah remember
you received what did people say yeah
when I started uh most people were like
um oh it's a gay brand it's for you know
it's for a couple of gay girls in the
Northwest you know and
um nah as the conversation has
progressed that's no longer the case
right what does that mean even gay girl
yeah yeah so so if I you know if I'd had
coffee if I'd start a coffee company
would it be gay coffee right if I'd had
a toothpaste able to be gay to the space
right obviously that didn't make sense
and I think now we understand that we
understand that there's a lot more
fluidity in that conversation
um and and there's a lot more ability to
express yourself so so companies that
have not been founded with your vision
from the ground up might in this
particular month have a line or a set of
branded items you know the ones I'm
talking about I think I know right and
they are sometimes accused of
commercializing their solidarity right
making a buck off of their Ally ship is
there a better way for companies to
approach it
look I love folks uh stepping into this
space and uplifting the lgbtq community
especially at this time of year I think
if you're going to do that and you are
going to make money off the community
you better make sure you're there to
support them too right and that looks
like standing behind them when they need
it that looks like donations so we've
given back over a million dollars to
Charities that we support right so
making sure you're putting your money
where your mouth is why is that
important to you to give back because a
lot of a lot of Brands say we do but
then you check the books and they really
don't or we'll get to it later yeah let
us grow first I think it comes back to
the question you asked me before about
putting your consumer at the heart of
everything you do it matters to our
consumer right it's it's table Stakes
for them and so as a result it is for us
too
well Emma we appreciate you joining us
we love the brand love the name of it
yeah what is Wild Thing how to sing in
one of our favorite songs all morning I
know
but what does wildfang mean what does it
mean to you you know when I was looking
for a name for the company I I find this
word wildifying it has German roots and
to me it sounded like it was either a
rock band or it was a kid's book and and
that's what I wanted for the brand right
I wanted the ferociousness and rawness
of the Rock Brand and then I wanted the
safety and comfort of the community so
hopefully it's got both I'm glad you
like it of course did you bring us any
clothes
I did bring Gale clothes
oh man I thought it was for everybody
now I'm joking um thank you so much for
joining us thank you for everybody but
she said she wasn't sure I would have
wear you know I mean I like I like all
of it I promise I will hook all three of
you up I just wanted to start with the
most fashionable oh you're right oh no
no well done well done no he wins he
wins in the fashion
receive the compliment him let's move on